well a short while ago we heard from the
incumbent chancellor of the exchequer on
the rise in the energy price cap in the
past few moments the conservative
leadership candidate and former
chancellor of the ex-checker richie
sunak has been speaking on the same
matter
this is the most pressing challenge
facing the country i've said that
consistently and as chancellor i
announced significant support to help
people but the situation is deteriorated
as prime minister i would go further my
priority is to protect the most
vulnerable in society including
pensioners and i want them to have
certainty that extra help is coming
that's what i would put in place but
that represents a choice it's the right
thing to do but i want to prioritize
those people alternative plans which are
doing different things borrowing tens of
billions of pounds for permanent
unfunded tax cuts don't actually do
anything to help the people most in need
risk making inflation worse and put our
nation's finances at risk as well my
plan my priority is the right one for
our country
should the government have allowed this
price cap announcement to happen without
any matching announcement on support
well people can judge me by my track
record when the price cap estimate last
came out when i was chancellor i
announced significant support which
meant for the most vulnerable in our
society almost the entire increase in
energy bills was covered and they were
going to receive extra assistance to
help with those bills it was
acknowledged as being commensurate with
the scale of the challenge targeted at
the people most in need that's my track
record in grappling with this issue i
moved quickly as chancellor and this
will be my immediate priority as prime
minister and i'd like to try and do the
same thing and make sure that we protect
the most vulnerable as much as we can
from this significant increase in bills